[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS BANES: So,
hello Android Dev
Summit and welcome to the
Support Library Guts and Glory.
My name is Chris Banes and I'm
an engineer on the developer
relations team.
I've been at Google now for
roughly three years, always
working on support libraries.
ADAM POWELL: And
I'm Adam Powell.
You may have seen me
earlier this morning.
I've been at Google for
five, six years now,
working on Android UI
toolkit and framework.
CHRIS BANES: Right,
so when I first
started thinking about
this talk It was originally
going to be like a deep dive
on sort of the internals, sort
of support libraries, how
we've implemented them
and all that kind of stuff.
But then I realized that there's
a lot of developers out there
that don't actually know some
of the basics, how we actually
architect it.
So how you actually use it
and why you would use it.
So we've got these
five questions of why--
around the support library.
So what it is, why you use it,
some implications of using it,
how, and then some bugs.
So let's first about
what it actually is.
ADAM POWELL: So--
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, go on.
ADAM POWELL: Sure.
So, what's included?
The support library started out
as this very small component.
We had the support-v4.jar.
It was a very simple
piece, no resources, just
a little bit of
code that you could
add into your applications and
it provided some extra stuff
that you could statically
link in your applications
to gain more functionality.
Over time, it's grown.
It's grown into a number
of other libraries
so saying the Android support
library hasn't really been
accurate for several years now.
And so we started growing
all these extra features,
we've started adding
resources, and today this
is really an integral part of
building any modern Android
application.
So the rough layout
or diagram of how
the support
libraries look today,
looks something like this.
So, off to one side, we have
a series of feature libraries
that are really
pretty standalone.
They don't have a whole lot
of extra interdependencies.
We've got stuff like the new
customtabs library for browsers
to use, we have GridLayout,
cardview stands on its own,
and we have the palette library
for extracting information
from images.
There are probably
a few more in there,
but this kind of gives
you the basic idea.
We have the core that is still
this basic support v4 library
that we have from
the very beginning.
Now, this really provides
a number of API shims
for newer APIs that
have been added
to the platform since
a given release.
A lot of people
ask, OK, well YV4.
where does this come from.
Well, it comes from
what the min SDK
level is for your application
when you use this library.
So we support all the
way back to donut,
which is I understand
still has many users today.
Wait, no.
So again, we've had
some legacy in here
and you'll start to see that
in some of this as well.
Some of the reasons for the
design of the support library
and kind of how it's grown.
It's grown very organically.
So in addition to API
shins for new things,
we've got back ports
of several items.
So for example, the fragment
library from the fragment
system that was introduced
in Android 3.0 Honeycomb,
is available to
all applications.
Even before that,
as and again we
have a large, large number
of users on devices that old
these days.
However the fragment
support library
has kept up to date with newer
features such as embedded child
fragments and similar features.
We've got other
standalone features,
things like Viewpager.
You'll recognize Viewpager
from any sort of tab
UI across Android these days.
This component doesn't
actually have a representation
in the Android framework
as a public API,
instead this just exists as
part of the support library
that you can use anywhere.
This is a feature that's
become very stable over time.
On top of the support-v4
libraries and sort
of the infrastructural
shims that they support,
you've got items
like RecyclerView.
So, you just sat through
a wonderful presentation
about RecyclerView here.
RecyclerView, internally
uses a lot of those API shims
to access functionality
that may or may not
be available under the hood.
It's the sort of layering
that we've really
tried to set up across some of
the support librarries so far.
Going a step further,
we have some polyfills.
So we have backported large
chunks of the UI toolkit
as it's advanced forward
in terms of material design
and even hollow before it, in
the form of the app compiled
library.
Now, this really tries to track
a lot of the other framework
changes that have had.
So it just sort of fills in
any missing functionality
in older versions
of the platform.
Now with that as a base, we've
built some other components
that sit on top of these layers.
We have things like
Mediarouter, which
services all of
the cast endpoints
for talking to Chromecast
devices and similar.
We have the design
libraries which
provide all sorts of modern
material design components
on top of the basis that
AppCompat has created.
We have preferences system which
updates the preferences system
that you know and love
from the Android framework
to also work on
other form factors.
And we've got the
Leanback Library,
which allows you to create
great 10-foot UI experiences.
So, why do we have all this?
Well, part of this was
about the release cycle.
So we want to be able to
do some unbundled releases
and get more of these features
out to developers sooner.
We also wanted to be
able to get bug fixes out
on an app developer's schedule,
not on a platform release
schedule.
And we also wanted to make
new features available
in between these
releases, as well.
So in this case,
a static library
is really more the
tool to use here.
You, as the app developer,
are in alternate control
of when you update this code.
However, that also means
that you don't automatically
take advantage of
updates and bug fixes
that are released perhaps
off cadence from your own app
releases.
So it's double edged.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
So hopefully, over the
past couple of releases
you've seen that
we've been doing
more and more interim releases.
So previously, the
support library
has always tied to
platform release.
But since 21, I
was the last one,
we've been doing more and
more interim releases.
And that's because the
support libraries have become
more and more important
to you guys, which
means that we need to
start fixing things quicker
and we know that.
ADAM POWELL: So RecyclerView is
one example of the components
that we've got in here.
Again, we just sat through a
whole talk based on that alone.
We've got data-set windowing
within a larger data set.
Improves upon similar framework
components such ListView.
And it also supports nested
scrolling by way of the V4 ship
APIs we've made available.
So, just a quick run
through since you
just saw a bunch
of this content.
Plug the talk that
was here before,
if you missed it go ahead
and go watch the video.
Animations are prime
example of something
that we were able to offer
in RecyclerView that we
couldn't necessarily
back port to existing
versions of ListView.
Being able to make this
available to previous platform
versions was one of the reasons
RecyclerView was developed
in the manner that it was.
It's pluggable.
So you can provide your
own components and pieces.
Layout managers,
item decorations,
treatment of
recycled view pools,
all the complexity that you
may want to add to this or not.
And it really tries to enforce
some better practices that
built up around something
like ListView over time.
AppCompat.
CHRIS BANES: AppCompat.
So, AppCompat--
ADAM POWELL: It's his baby.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
So this is the thing
I've been working on
since I joined Google.
It's my starter
project, actually.
And it generally trying to be
a massive polyfill of the UI
toolkit.
Now, as the UI
toolkit has changed
over the different
platform releases,
we tried to keep
AppCompat up to date.
So, originally it started out
as an action bar backport.
And I'm sure you were
all using the action bar
shell at the time.
Now, and many question why we
actually released an action bar
compact, which is this.
And now the reason
why we did that
is so that we can give
you what it is today.
So that's a base that
we built and now we've
kept outside the framework.
And, so yeah.
It backports framework features,
but one thing you'll notice,
it goes no further.
It will never add new features
that aren't in the framework.
And its goal is to always stay
up to date with the framework.
We may be a release sort
of behind, but with those
interim releases that
we talked about earlier.
We will never be too far.
So there are three
main things which
I think AppCompat gives you.
The first, is it's themes.
It gives you one theme
to extend or use,
which works and looks most of
the same across all different
API levels.
So, that's including
Gingerbread,
if it's a hollow,
if it's a material.
It gives you one thing to use.
Second, is Toolbar.
Now, as we said
earlier we give you
the action bar and in API 11.
But there was always
this black box.
Right?
You couldn't really control it.
You can Animate it,
you never really
had much control over it.
And so toolbar is
the manifestation
of that as an actual widget.
You control it
from top to bottom.
Vary it's new hierarchy.
You can animate it,
you can scroll it,
you can do whatever
you want with it.
And secondly, Tinting.
It's probably wrong
time for this,
but in [INAUDIBLE] .material,
we've given these new
attributes, which can control
the look and feel of your app.
Frees colors and stuff.
Now, AppCompat tries
to do that as well,
using its own attributes.
There are certain things,
which before don't quite work,
so it's really important to
test and make sure it does.
So we'll move on
to Design library.
Which is kind of the library
above AppCompat, which means
it goes beyond the framework.
Anything in Design
library, is stuff
that isn't in the framework.
It's a UI feature library,
which tries to implement
material design instructions.
And so the stuff that
we think it is stable
and that are good
instructions to use.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah.
More specifically,
the Design library
offers us an outlet for
all of these components
that may have sort
of a fashion life
cycle associated with them.
You can probably think
of a number of components
over the years, that
we've introduced,
that maybe haven't
stood the test of time.
Some of these components
in the Android framework
today have been
marked as deprecated,
such as Android.Widget.Gallery
and some similar things
that you may be able to recall.
This basically
gives us an ability
to still iterate, follow
some of these other trends
as they move forward, but
still give you something
that you can reasonably rely on.
CHRIS BANES: So there's
four things which I
think Design library gives you.
The high value stuff basically.
FloatingActionButton is probably
the most ubiquitous one.
It's the thing where you
think material design.
It's that circular button.
Now there are some nuances
to how the UX spec is done.
Which FloatingActionButton
actually sort of does for you.
It's really--
ADAM POWELL: It's just
an image button, though?
Right?
I mean, how hard could it be?
CHRIS BANES: Well,
its just-- yeah.
Exactly.
The shadows really..
So it's just--
Yeah-- Going on that,
actually, so it won't
be probably don't
know is that there's actually
a small little machine on FAB.
It took me about a
week to implement.
So you-- to actually
use it is really easy.
Just place it into
your layout, you
can change the icon
which is displayed.
And there's some other stuff
that you can do, as well.
But FloatingActionButton
handles certain stuff
like it has the correct
Show and Hide animation,
it handles itself
nicely with SnapBar.
There's quite a lot
of functionality
built straight into it.
Secondly, is NavigationView.
Now, material design is
quite prescriptive about how
the site nav is displayed
and how it's laid out.
And we've tried to give
you this sort of stock
off the shelf component.
Which you can drag straight into
draw layout and it just works.
What it is the new
layout, it's pretty easy.
There's two things
you should look at.
The first is header layout.
So that is the sort of header.
It's a reference to
another layout, which
will be displayed as a header.
Usually, it'll be like
some kind of switch
up some kind of branding.
The second thing is menu.
So that is actually
what gets populated
into the NavigationView.
Now we're using
menu because it's
something you've already used.
It's been there since API one.
You've probably used
it for options menu,
that kind of stuff.
So you know exactly
how to use it.
ADAM POWELL: More
specifically, it's declared.
So it's easy for
tools to access.
CHRIS BANES: Exactly.
Snackbar, which is
the kind of new way
to show temporary information.
It's a bit different to
Toast in that it allows
you to add an action to it.
And also, it's swappable.
There's a small
thing here where you
can see that the FAB moves
up as the Snackbar comes in.
That's all inbuilt
functionality, that
just happens automatically.
See here.
And then lastly, this Tablayer.
Now there are two types of tabs.
Which is quite a mouthful.
So there's fixed tabs on the
left, where each tab takes
the same amount of space.
And I'm grateful when you
have a small number of tabs,
so you know there's going
to be three or four that
are going to fit.
On my right, you've
got scrollable.
So they're for times when
you have an unknown number.
So [INAUDIBLE] layout,
again, just tab layout.
The attribute here to
look at is Tab Mode
and you can switch between
scrollable and fixed.
Now that we know that most
people using TabLayout
are going to use it
with a ViewPager.
So we have this method set
up with ViewPager, which
handles all of it for you.
Populates the TabLayout,
it sets the listeners
so they all interact together.
Works quite nicely.
ADAM POWELL: All right.
So we've added some other
things more recently, as well.
Inspired by Android
Wear and really
trying to get a lot of
other proportional layouts
on a very small screen.
We've got several variants on
existing layout managers that
have been in the framework
for a while that now accepts
percentages, as well as
the standard measurements
that you know and love.
So we've got frame layout
and relative layout here.
And you can define
sizes of elements
as a percentage of their parent,
rather than just as a wrap
content or specific sizes.
This differs from weight
in a few important ways.
Just in terms of how it adds
up over time as elements
come and go.
So weight, it's
oftentimes a little bit
awkward to go ahead
and sort of remeasure
and rethink how some of
the stuff would layout.
Where as the percentage makes it
much easier to express in line.
So, this adds a couple of
specific layout params,
attributes that you'll
want to know about.
They work about how
they sound like they
should from the description.
So we have some Gotchas
in the support libraries.
CHRIS BANES: No.
ADAM POWELL: No.
Never.
So, when you're building
against the support libraries,
the library major
version number really
is the minimum
Compile SDK version
that you need to declare.
This is something that trips
up a number of developers
and this is something
that isn't always clear
just from the outset.
We get a lot of variants
on this question
as people move over to a
new release of the support
libraries.
Hey, my builds broken, why?
This is probably why.
So as we increment the
library major version number,
you also need to compile against
the latest SDK in addition
to that.
CHRIS BANES: Have we
just leaked API 24?
ADAM POWELL: There's going
to be an API 24 everybody,
you heard it here first.
So this is another number that
you're probably familiar with.
Not only is it a handy
dandy power of two,
it's also the decks
method reference limit.
So, how big are all these
support libraries anyway?
Well AppCompat is kind of a
few in terms of that method.
v4 libaries, hmm OK.
Well, that's a
little bit bigger.
Design library and
RecyclerView too.
OK.
Well, that's kind
of a big number.
That's also a lot to
ask developers to devote
to some of these components.
So--
CHRIS BANES: Sorry,
one thing to notice
that is that that's a
theoretical maximum.
There will actually be some
double accounts in that number,
as well.
Just because like
those support libraries
will be referenced
in framework methods.
Now, if you use
those same methods,
they won't be counted twice.
ADAM POWELL: Right.
So there's a little bit of
folding that happens here,
but it also starts incrementing
the count pretty quickly.
So, many of you have
probably already
figured out that you can use
handy dandy proguard tools
to take care of some
of this problem.
You can set
minifyEnabled to true
across the
Android.support package.
And well, that's a little
bit more manageable than what
we had before.
Of course, the more of the
support libraries you use,
the more you're going
to be pulling in.
The Cheesesquare
example app, so far we
were able to cut down
over half of that
and it still uses a fair number
of the pieces of functionality
available.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I
wanted to know that.
That is the very
basic proguard config.
You could go further into that
and start stripping more stuff.
ADAM POWELL: That's right.
So of course, proguard
isn't optimal.
Especially when you're in a
sort of very tight modify,
compile, debug, run, test
type of development cycle.
At that point, you'll
have plenty of time
to check your favorite
social media sites
before that has done and
installs on your device.
However, I think that there was
this really cool demo earlier
this morning that might be able
to help out with some of that.
Now that we have the
new features in studio
to shorten that cycle, that'll
help out with this as well.
So whereas before,
it wasn't really
something that you
wanted to do to enable
this type of stripping
just straight
out of the box on every build.
Now, it's at least a little
bit more of a palatable option
if your application's
starting to get large.
CHRIS BANES: So one thing
that one sort of strategy I've
heard from some of
you guys really,
is that most engineers
will use a multidex for day
to day development.
Just to quicken proguard
for the deeper build
and then when you actually
wanted to release,
that's when you
turn on proguard.
And so that tends to be
a strategy, which sounds
like it should work well.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah.
It comes along with
other costs as well.
Especially if you're doing
any sort of optimization
of startup time, that comes
at some other costs as well.
Anyway, there's a
lot of trade offs,
but there are options available.
So don't think you're
stuck when you run up
against some of these problems.
CHRIS BANES: And one
thing to actually say
that we know that
this is problem.
Like, we know that
support-v4 is quite large.
And we are thinking of ways
to improve the situation.
Like we know.
ADAM POWELL: The
short version of it
is, we're going to
delete a lot of code.
OK.
So, how are we going to
delete a lot of code?
No, how do we use--
CHRIS BANES: How do we use it?
So, we all I'm guessing we're
using Gradle these days,
and so we just add the
library to your dependency.
But one thing I've seen sort of
in quite a lot of open source
apps, is that you'll be using
more than one support library.
And then you'll forget
to update the version
number on one of them and
then it'll get out sync.
And then bad stuff can happen.
So this is just a small tip
and I'm sure most of you
are using this anyway.
Is that you can extract the
version number into a variable
in your Gradle file.
And then you can use
it, you can reference it
in that dependency line.
So after that, actually
clicked, there you go.
Your dependencies [INAUDIBLE].
What it means is that whenever
you want to update your version
number, whenever
you want to move up
to a new version
of support library,
you can change just one line and
it works for everything else.
And it means you're
going hit less problems
and also less time mindly
editing Gradle files.
ADAM POWELL: Which, you know.
Everyone wants to
spend less time there.
OK.
So, bugs in the support library.
CHRIS BANES: There's
never any bugs.
ADAM POWELL: No.
CHRIS BANES: So, [INAUDIBLE].
We know there are bugs.
They're always going to be
bugs in the support library.
Just because the-- just
the nature of what it is,
we have to support all the
way back to API version four,
and support v4, AppCompat
v7, all the others.
So there are some times going
to be bugs, we know that.
And so, we are very grateful for
when you actually submit stuff.
Hopefully, you'll see that
we're pretty hard on it.
We will assign stuff
pretty quickly.
Even though we don't release
as quickly as what some of you
would like, we know
that it's something
that we should improve.
ADAM POWELL: And
this is something
where we've got a number
of things in progress.
We have heard you.
We got a lot of feedback from
the last couple of releases
that we had that were maybe
a little bit rougher than we
would have preferred.
And we're working on it.
So this is something that if
there's some more stuff that we
missed, please submit them.
This is not just a
black box that you're
going to throw stuff,
throw reports down into
and we won't read.
We do keep an eye
on these things.
CHRIS BANES: One thing to
know as well, actually,
when you open a bug
on AOSP, there's
a little box at the
top, which allows
you to change what type of bug.
When you select support library.
It'll come with a template.
Please follow the template.
For things like design library,
where a lot of the bugs
tend to be with scrolling,
you trying to describe in text
isn't going to really--
like it doesn't help me.
You giving me a screen record
of how it actually looks
is much easier for me to
actually debug and work out
what's happening.
And just saves me time, and it
saves you guys time as well.
ADAM POWELL: All right.
So, we have saved plenty of
time because support library
is one of those topics
that everybody has
something to talk about for.
So we'd like to open
up the floor for Q&A.
CHRIS BANES: Maybe not.
No.
ADAM POWELL: We've got one
over here and one over here.
We have the mics up?
OK, they're coming.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so we have the
very nice FloatingActionButton
in this design library.
Is the FloatingActionButton
menu coming soon?
CHRIS BANES: You
mean like speed dial?
Like inbox style
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
CHRIS BANES: Do you
mean like speed dial?
The inbox style
of when it pops up
with a little floating badge?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the plus
that changes into a cross
and pops up the items.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM POWELL: The design
team is playing around
with a bunch of other
ideas around this.
one of the things that
tends to happen, especially
with the design library,
is-- Well, let me back up
for a second.
We mentioned before that when
we put a component into the AOSB
support libraries, we really
want it to be something
that we're fully
willing to endorse
this particular pattern.
A lot of the Google
applications such as inbox
have done a bunch of their own
explorations, down one path
or another, that kind of extend
some of these basic ideas
so far.
The design team hasn't been
willing to entirely put
their stamp of approval on
this to the point of saying,
hey we want to see this
in every Android app
and we think that this
and all of the details
behind this pattern are
something that we want
to really standardize
on and give
to developers as this sort of
full story for the platform.
So, as soon as
that happens you'll
see this showing up in the
design support library.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, and if you
look at this material design
spec, it doesn't really
mention the speed dial anymore.
It mentions, it's
quite general like,
transitions I
think they call it.
And so we are looking
at writing some
of the transitions
between things,
but it's still early days.
We're not there yet.
AUDIENCE: Can't they
watch the space.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
ADAM POWELL: Got one up
front, or another over--
AUDIENCE: What's your policy
on trying to resolve or if you
want to resolve crashes that
come up from manufacturers such
as Samsung or HTC that's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ADAM POWELL: So,
I believe what it
is that you're referring to
is that on some devices that
are out there, there
is a potentially
older version of
support libraries that
are on the default classpath.
This is something that we're
working with manufacturers on.
To try and help with this.
And in the meantime, we're
going to offer some other work
arounds that will
hopefully make your lives,
as developers, a
little bit easier.
AUDIENCE: With like
the Gradle build
tool or the other
libraries in there,
like Maven repo online
or anything like that.
And the support
libraries, you have
to download it to
your local machine
and trying to keep
that up to date
has been very frustrating
and hard at times.
Is there a way to move that
to a centralized repo, where
we can just get access to, or--
ADAM POWELL: So, I
think that's probably
a good question for some
of the Android tools team.
They'll be outside available
at probably the kiosk that
says Android Studio.
Also probably a great
question to bring up
at like the fireside chat
around tools, as well.
AUDIENCE: Are there
any plan of bringing
animations to GridView,
similar to RecyclerView?
ADAM POWELL: To GridView
similar to a RecyclerView.
I believe that the plan on that
is to build more grid layout
managers for
RecyclerView so that it
inherits all the
animation capabilities
the RecyclerView has.
GridView right now is
based on the same internals
that ListView is,
within the framework,
and for all the same
reasons it's basically
hit its complexity
budget in terms of this.
There's a number
of tactics that you
can use to try to do
similar animations
in GridView and in ListView.
And all of them end up having
some pretty drastic downsides
to them, in terms of what you're
able to do from an application
code or from something like
a support library in there.
So we would really suggest
using a RecyclerView layout
manager meant to
layout within a grid
to get that type
of functionality.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
there's already two,
off the top of my
head, there's already
two grid layout managers
bundled with RecyclerView.
There's GridLayout manager and
there's Staggered GridLayout
manager, and they both do
slightly different things
in terms of how they
deal with spacing.
But yeah, they're already there.
So you can have a look.
AUDIENCE: So RecyclerView is
its own standalone component
and has its own
standalone library
or is, like you
mentioned before,
something like Viewpager, which
doesn't exist in the framework,
but it's just part of the core.
In the future, can
we expect to see
things like that that
aren't in the framework,
but are standalone in
their own libraries?
ADAM POWELL: You also saw
this with Grid Layout,
as an example of something else
that kind of sat on its own.
Most of the reason for
this is kind of historical.
We started off with
the v4 support library
and due to some
limitations in our internal
build tools at the time.
This was all like pre-Gradle,
pre-AAR, and things like that.
We couldn't have
resources in there,
so we had a bunch
of other pieces.
I mean, this is
part of the reason
why you can't do nice things
with attributes in your layouts
for things like Viewpager.
Whereas, if we were
doing that today
we would totally add all
these additional pieces.
So now we basically
have this issue
of like keeping
source compatibility
with a lot of current
developer's builds
and so on and so
forth around that.
I think that the design
library approach is probably
the one to expect with things
with a forward facing UI
component.
RecyclerView is a
little bit unique
in that it's
basically a framework
for writing ListViews.
And to that end, it
kind of sits on its own
just because it's a little bit
more infrastructural instead
of the full, out of the
box, turnkey components.
I would probably expect
to see some things based
on RecyclerView start
making their way
into some other libraries
that kind of sit
on that layer of
abstraction above.
CHRIS BANES:
[INAUDIBLE] backward
makes huge use of RecyclerView.
ADAM POWELL: That's
a perfect example.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Any plans or suggestions for
doing animations in Viewpagers?
Specifically, like remove
and add animations there?
ADAM POWELL: That's
also a great question.
So, I've kind of had this
idea kicking around my head
for awhile that at
some point Viewpager
would be updated into
sort of the New World
into kind of a new Viewpager
two based on top RecyclerView.
In which case, again,
just like with GridView,
you'd kind of inherit a lot of
that functionality for free.
We haven't gotten around to
doing that sort of thing yet.
But if you were
feeling so inclined
to build something
kind of like that,
and you feel like you want
to take a crack at it,
that's probably
how I would start.
In terms of Viewpager's
current system,
what types of animations
are you thinking of?
I mean we do have a little
bit of capability in there
around the lines of
page transformers.
And that allows you to
get kind of what we always
called the cafeteria tray
style, that we used to use
in the paged launcher all apps.
Couple of versions ago.
You can also use it to get quite
a few other effects as you're
paging through things.
So, what were you thinking
of, more specifically?
Oh, sorry.
They took your mic.
AUDIENCE: Specifically, actually
add and remove animations.
So removing pages from it.
And also being, maybe this is
a little too far out, but--
ADAM POWELL: Be
far out, come on.
AUDIENCE: Being able to
fling multiple pages.
But land on page boundaries.
ADAM POWELL: I see.
Yeah, this--
CHRIS BANES: Sounds
like Gallery.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it actually does.
And so we have this
wonderful deprecated widget
in the framework that
you can take a look.
No.
So, again, this is one
of those features that's
kind of a well known feature
request for RecyclerView
in general, which is
being able to stop
on item [INAUDIBLE] boundaries.
This is something
that a number of teams
have wanted for a number of
other types of applications,
but the core piece
of functionality
remains the same for all of it.
It's just kind of
like spin it around
along on the other,
access of scrolling,
make the item sizes
either uniform or not,
it all kind of boils down to
the same thing in the end.
So that's something
that we're definitely
thinking about in
terms of RecyclerView
as an infrastructure component.
CHRIS BANES: Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Over here.
Hello, could we expect some of
the material spec components
to be out at any time soon?
Something like the bottom sheet?
CHRIS BANES: Maybe.
ADAM POWELL: Yes, so--
CHRIS BANES: So bottom sheet's
a weird one in that there's
two types of bottom sheets.
From what I remember
of the spec,
they're not too prescriptive
about what the content is.
It's more the interaction.
So the thing it will
be concentrated on
is the interaction as that's
probably the most difficult
thing to get.
Right?
So that might be coming soon.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, so,
Chris is being very cagey.
Basically, I would say that
in the fullness of time,
I think it's our ideal that the
designer library would reflect
the contents of the
material design spec.
CHRIS BANES: The important
bits, the high-- the stuff
you're going to use.
ADAM POWELL: So
the parts we like?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
It might be.
Well the stuff that
we want people to use.
ADAM POWELL: Yes.
Which, again--
CHRIS BANES: All of it, I guess.
OK.
I'll shut up.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
wondering if there
are any plans for like
supporting font features
in the support library?
So on newer versions
of the Android,
there's the Roboto font.
So for example, in a navigation
view, for example, in the spec
it's supposed to be a
medium font which does not
exist on older API levels.
So, or like in the
toolbar, so are there
any plans for supporting
fonts in that kind of way?
ADAM POWELL: You went to Rey's
talk earlier, didn't you?
On the typography?
Yeah.
So yeah, that was a
good piece of feedback
especially from within
that talk's Q&A, as well.
So thank you for that, we'll try
and make that a little bit more
extensible.
At least so that you can get
those sorts of things plummed
down into those widgets
that do sort of generate
their own items
that contain text.
I think that's a great
piece of feedback.
One of the other things that
some people found pretty early
after the introduction of
the data binding system,
and this may not
apply necessarily
to like the navigation
of your toolbar issues
that you're bringing forth here,
but with regard to other font
features people
found that they can
use a couple little snippets
of code within the data binding
system to apply some
pretty interesting font
tricks to existing views.
So I would probably use
your favorite search engine
and try and dig up
some of those posts.
And take a look at
some of the stuff
that they've done
because it really
does help to fill some of
those gaps around font features
in particular.
Got one back here.
AUDIENCE: I really liked
the nested scrolling concept
that like we're seeing now.
So my question is, do you
have any tips or tricks
on developing,
debugging, testing,
like code that's related
to gesture handling?
Cause there was a bug
in nested scrolling
I think in the
RecyclerView and that
was really difficult to debug.
CHRIS BANES: If only the man
who wrote nested scrolling
was here.
ADAM POWELL: Oh, now you're
just reusing Chet's jokes.
CHRIS BANES: Good.
ADAM POWELL: So, which
bug are you referring to?
I mean I guess yes
it can definitely
be a little bit brain bending to
deal with the nested scrolling
stuff.
It's part of the
reason why we're
trying to make a little bit
more turnkey in general.
Just with some of
the components that
are part of the design library,
and so on and so forth.
So what were some of
the specific issues
that you ran into and we can
try and take that into account
for the future?
AUDIENCE: Well,
the example it was
when you're fleeing a
RecyclerView and I had another,
I've forgotten the name
of it, but basically
implementing a parallax effect.
For example.
The fleeing was actually
at the velocity lessened
to the point view that was
being parallax animated
was the wrong direction.
Things like that.
And it was like when you scroll
thing, when you fling it,
it was like it was
moving along nicely
and then it just went to the--
ADAM POWELL: Bounces back the
completely opposite direction.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And we see in the Cheesesquare.
If you haven't tried
the latest version
of RecyclerView or of
the support v7 libraries.
But supposedly, it's fixed.
I haven't tried it yet though.
CHRIS BANES: We know the issue.
AUDIENCE: So I'm just
wondering like do
you have any tips and tricks
in terms of when you developed
this kind of thing.
CHRIS BANES: So the
difficulty with debugging
this kind of stuff, is
when you start moving
the view at the same time.
So that's when it
gets more difficult.
Which is why this
particular bug has
been quite hard to track down.
We think we're there now.
We think we're there.
Basically--
ADAM POWELL: Chris is
being cagey about it,
but yes we were actually
looking at exactly this problem
last week.
CHRIS BANES: Yes.
ADAM POWELL: This
bug in particular.
So yes, we're sorry.
CHRIS BANES: That's
one of the things
with nested scrolling
actually because, I mean,
the API is great.
But each view which
implements it,
does it slightly differently.
That's one of the reasons
why this kind of issue
is so crop up.
ADAM POWELL: Cause
I mean, some of this
is just kind of goes to the
way that RecyclerView is
a really great example of this.
If one piece of scrolling code
covered every possible use
case, then we would have
been done with ScrollView.
So RecyclerView and
other things scroll
by completely
different mechanisms
for one reason or
another, and it ends up
leading to bugs that hopefully
you never see externally.
And unfortunately,
this one made it out.
CHRIS BANES: Anyone else?
No more?
ADAM POWELL: Going
once, going twice.
OK.
CHRIS BANES: Thank you.
ADAM POWELL: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]